i've been hosting for a long time you're
hosting this show you can't say much
about it but you're hosting this
right down in the cayman islands which
is basically you're describing the gig i
want
not the gig i have it's a dream what do
you learn i am on
a set i've never been on location have
you ever been on location going to where
you're like
it's like summer camp where you're with
people for like over a month
and you forget about there's a world
outside of the show it's like this
bubble it happened to me on dancing with
the stars where i was like
i got kicked off dancing the stars i
actually i got um
well i got first uh voted off is how i
like to say it but
i as soon as i got off the show i didn't
know how to like
walk around in the real world i was just
like i can't i was like dancing is life
and i can't do anything else i can't go
back to comedy because you get convinced
that that's all that matters right and
i'm on the show right now where
yeah it's intense have you been on
location before i haven't uh the closest
i've come
is based doing travel shows but no then
i'm always on the move so no i haven't
done i haven't done that kind of gig
and now what i'm curious about is now
that you're hosting
what are you learning about yourself as
a host what is
what is nikki glazer like as a host i've
been watching other hosts obviously i
my goal is to be a team like i love tv
hosting you are
huge influence on me um and pretty much
no one else like i
i i'm obsessed with you and um i know
and i've seen
i've and you are one of these heroes
that i meet where you go
oh he's not as good as i thought he's
gonna be you're just as good if not
like better and more personable like
off-camera
at least to me thank you but then you
find out
and you're you seem to be good to the
people you work with like from what i've
seen
but you find out when you talk to like
the crew and get to know these people
who have worked on sets
that the stories that seem cartoonish of
celebrities having these
egos of like no eye contact on set
things that you think are just
mythical are actually real like there
are celebrities that
you and i love who you and i probably
have met before who would only be nice
to us because we're celebrities
but they treat people like trash and
they literally will not allow eye
contact there's several
people that i don't want to name because
i'm scared of them and they're powerful
but
i i find that to be so uh just
disheartening and awful and so i try to
be really nice and have like a
connection with everyone in the crew
so i to juxtapose that i i've started
when i arrive on set
i make each crew member have four to
five minutes of uh deep connected eye
contact with me
and it's slowed down production quite a
bit we're about three weeks behind at
this point
and i've fallen in love with one key
grip and two gaffers and there's several
hr complaints
but and i don't really know what hr
stands for i'm assuming it stands for
handjobs rule i
i i don't know but well uh i haven't
looked it up either i don't
think that's what it means but uh until
i look it up
i can't be 100 sure you can't be sure
no one can really be sure what hr means
so i
um but yeah i've just made an extra
effort to be nice and to
make people who are working on the show
feel a part of the show because
there is just this divide of celebrities
and it's not just about the celebrity
thinking they're better than everyone
else
a lot of times people just put that on
celebrities and i'm not even speaking
for myself
i do this too where you you don't you
see someone in public that you really
admire and you i don't want to bother
them
or i don't i don't want to tell them how
much i love them because they hear it
all day
but because of that everyone thinks we
hear it all day
and so no one says it to us right i
literally had to call
like the executives of the show like my
bosses and go you aren't complimenting
me enough
and they go oh well you're great we
figured you knew
like how we gave you this job and i go i
am a celebrity because i am so desperate
for love
from strangers and anywhere i can get it
you will never give me a big enough big
head where i
it will never be enough so please please
compliment me and i've done that in my
own life like
i know that you know i write about the
bystander effect in
the one day i went to my psychology
class in college and i wasn't hungover
and i learned that
kitty genovese in 1964 was stabbed to
death
38 people heard her screams for help no
one called the cops because everyone
thought someone else was calling the
cops we do this all the time
oh someone else will do it and then no
one does it and you
she bleeds to death on the sidewalk and
and and that's what it's like when you
don't tell me my hair looks good i'm
bleeding to death
no it's not it's extreme but you're
you're comparing
you're comparing you're laughing you're
com you're saying it's the same thing
it's pretty much the same thing and i'm
not disagreeing
but it's the same thing that uh you not
getting enough praise
on the set of your reality show is
pretty much the same
as the stabbing death of kitty genovese
in 1964.
yeah i i um those are i'm saying i'm
it's exactly the same yes and um and yes
so thank you for understanding me
there's
there is no uh nuance here or
exaggeration
yeah i'm being literal i feel yes uh
just as abandoned but
conan do you relate to that i mean you
must because even when i'm around you
i hesitate to gush about how much
i love you um and what i think of you
because i'm just like he hears it all
the time
he must he's like the funniest person
he's not like he is the funniest person
alive i've always said that
and that's but do you do you relate to
that conan that people
sometimes don't say something to you
because they're like you hear it all the
time and you're like no more
well that's the problem is that uh it's
a no-win situation
because um what happens is first of all
if it's someone like you like an
attractive woman that's all i dreamed
about
when i was a kid and in my teens and
through my 20s and then well into my 30s
was
a very attractive woman complimenting me
that was my dream so that's not going to
go away
i'm not going to lie i love that
but at the same time
what happens is self-loathing kicks in
and so you compensate for it
and it gets very complicated and so what
i've found is that compliments don't
last compliments are like tic tacs
and when someone says something critical
that's like a roast beef dinner that's
in your belly for
six months so i don't know why like you
can get a thousand tic tacs
and you don't feel anything but then one
person says
one thing uh and
you never forget it i don't know why
it's it's crazy but that's stuff
that's why i don't read comments like i
missed so many positive youtube comments
saying how
much you know they want to have sex with
me
and that and maybe saying that i'm like
pretty funny for a woman or whatever
and i miss all of those things that
really build me up
because i don't want to read the one
thing that says she's a little too
raunchy for me that's
that's the thing that i get is people
people like to give you compliments i
know you've had this
where they're like oh my god i love you
my dad doesn't get you
or like yes they have to like juxtapose
it with
someone that like i get you but this
table at the comedy club i was watching
them the whole time they
hated you how lame are they why do they
i've made them why do they think you
need to know that
why do they think you need to know i
don't know that someone else doesn't
like
you exactly i'm telling everyone out
there
don't don't count your compliment with
uh something else negative no one likes
it that way
and also like i people stop
telling me that like i people always
talk about my
comedy special i do talk about sex a lot
it's not because i'm like
i just want to challenge people and make
them uncomfortable around their
family it's because it's like what i
want to talk about that being said it
does make people uncomfortable sometimes
and i get that
stop watching my special with your
grandma
people are always like can't watch
nikki's special with your two-year-old
it's like
who's watching adult comedy specials
with their family surrounded by them
this isn't like
right lilo and stitch
[Laughter]
many times when my kids were younger i
made the mistake of saying
let's check out nikki's yeah let's let's
watch out
let's let's check out nick bangin and uh
and and they would be like what is it
i'd say it's pretty much like lilo and
stitch
and it never went well it never went
well
my son uh you know is scarred for life
that's the point that's the question you
read your comments and your comments are
uh or when people tell you about them
it's
um i would like to have sex with her and
that makes perfect sense
my thing is people who really like what
i do and are big fans with me
none of them want to have sex with me
that's not
it they don't i don't get that the
people who love my work say i love his
work and then if you said would you like
to just hold hands with him they'd say
absolutely not absolutely conan it
doesn't translate
it doesn't translate listen i don't have
that thing
i will not let you as someone who is not
a fan of conan
outside of you tell me how i process my
feelings about how funny you are
because you i don't want to say anything
out of turn but it does
equal sexiness and someone asked me the
other day
what celebrity is your uh hall pass and
i gave it
what did i say my friends here i gave it
to conan and dave matthews
oh you're kidding i don't mean to make
things weird but like yeah that's not
weird
you know what i love you waited till you
were out of the country to tell me this
that's why i feel safer telling this to
you now you waited until you had
if you came after me you'd have to
quarantine for two weeks what i love is
that you told me during a pandemic you
waited
until it's during a pandemic you're on a
secluded island
in quarantine and we're doing this over
zoom
and then you say and you say like by the
way you're my hall pass and it's a 24
hour
it ends in 24 hours that's fantastic
that's a great hall pass thank you it's
i don't even have all that i mean i'm
not even a relationship but i do
want to correct you and say and for any
man who's listening that like
aspires to be as funny and as prolific
as you are
that it women are attracted to funniness
i mean
funny it doesn't work the same way for
women i think i've talked to you about
this before like men aren't like she's
so
funny like i want her i want to be
inside her it's more like
just like the guys aren't turned on by
funniness but girls
very much are well first of all it's hot
i disagree
a lot of a lot of men including myself
are very turned on
by uh by by women that are funny and
make us laugh it's a huge
that's a that's a huge deal i've just
noticed that
whenever the world's most beautiful
women are interviewed
these supermodels they always say what
are you looking for in a man and the
first thing they always say is i want
him to be funny
and then a year later they always marry
the same douchey club owner do you know
what i mean who just happens to be worth
a billion dollars
and is the least funny person who ever
lived and they're like you don't know
what he's like when we're alone
conan yeah he likes he's so funny he
knows so many limericks
um oh my god like i that that to me is
you're you're right
funniness is first and and as a comedian
i think that i i can say that and people
will believe me but
you know i i don't feel like i can rest
on just being funny to attract the right
person i do feel like i have to do all
the other stuff and
right you know it's it's a it's a fair
balance but i do i do think that they're
i hear what you're saying yeah women
don't really show their work when they
say they're attracted to funny and uh
but but i will you will okay we'll get
to that later
much later i have to talk to a lawyer
and
it's very complicated i got to talk to
my wife and then three lawyers
um i'm so sorry to your beautiful wife
who i've stalked endlessly to be like
what can i do to be like her
how can i know how you guys met i know
the scene you shot together i know your
whole
love story it's very sweet well one of
the things i love about her is that she
would watch this and
and find it really hilarious like that's
her good
she would find it really hilarious and
um
she would anyone who professed their
love for me
she would take them aside and go uh
you're welcome
to take a shot um you will
you don't know what you're in for should
be like
uh you can if you want but i gotta tell
you
there's there's troubled waters there